[Music]
recently a friend of mine told me that
she felt guilty that she hadn't
accomplished more
during the last year the pandemic now
i've heard that a few times and
i have a feeling we're going to be
hearing that more and more as
vaccination rates
increase people are going to start
talking about the things they've
accomplished during the pandemic
as a way to measure their last year in
progress in things they've made and
things they've written
in money they've gained or changes
they've made to their lives that made
them better than they were in march of
2020
and it's going to seem like a
competition and that anyone who didn't
achieve very much
somehow lost but it's not a competition
and it's not a creative incubator or a
working vacation
it's a pandemic and you are not any
worse of a person for
living through a pandemic and not
accomplishing some big
project because you did the only thing
you had to
you lived you got up every day and
carried the weight of knowing that your
actions could put people in danger and
made the responsible choice to prevent
that you watched as the news got darker
and
darker and 3.3 million people around the
world
died as their government did little to
protect them
you wore a mask outside and lived with
the fear of worrying that other people
weren't wearing theirs
you watched as the understanding of this
disease became so convoluted that
people made up their own irresponsible
rules for how to handle it
you watched people protest for the
quote-unquote right
to walk around unmasked emboldened by
a fascist president who couldn't care
less if you lived or died
and then when vaccines finally started
rolling out
you watched as people denied their
efficacy
and risked extending the pandemic all
in the name of their so-called freedom
so
don't measure your last year and the
things you could have done
measure it in the things you had to do
with the unbearable trauma
of a worldwide crisis and pat yourself
on the back for waking up yet another
day because
that is the only accomplishment that
[Music]
matters
you